so then the person that will get me at
40 years old at 50 years old is getting
a different version than he had when I
was 18 20 years old but but it's a less
valuable version to me um no that's not
the right man for me because it's not
the right man for you it's how much like
men can't help what they're attraction
to no it is all a mess but they can't if
you survey men if you survey men between
the ages of 20 and 80 they're all the
most attracted to 22 year olds I peaked
three years ago and
and and and you guys did too whether you
yeah whether like yeah at 20 22 23 and
and this is men between the age of 20
and 80. so what men value is Purity
Youth and fertility and so like what
would you be able to offer to a guy